top dairy cow breeds around the
world best diary cow breeds of the
world
G originated in India known for its heat
resistance and ability to produce
highquality milk in tropical
climates
hallstein one of the most popular dairy
breeds in the world known for its large
milk production and its distinctive
white fur and black Rin NE
lands
gerzy renowned for its golden colored
milk and smooth flavor as well as being
efficient converters of food into milk
origin gy Island UK known for Golden
colored milk rich in beta
carotene
guzera it comes from Brazil valued for
its adaptability to warm climates and
its ability to produce good quality milk
geralando a cross between the G and
hallstein breeds seeking to combine G's
heat resistance with holstein's high
milk
production short
horn known for its versatility this
breed produces both highquality meat and
milk origin
England
Cindy originated in India adapted to
tropical climate climates and valued for
its ability to produce milk in harsh
conditions Swiss
parrot recognized for its great
efficiency in converting food into milk
and its brown fur origin
Switzerland
airer originated in Scotland known for
its adaptability and Longevity as well
as producing milk with high
solids origin SC
land in Du
Brazil a Brazilian breed known for its
adaptability and endurance as well as
its ability to produce milk in
challenging
conditions
Jersey valued for its milk rich and
solids especially in fat making it ideal
for producing dairy products like butter
and
cheese origin Jersey Island UK known for
rich creamy milk with high butterfat
content
cemental recognized for its large size
and ability to produce high quality milk
as well as being used for meat
production milking Devon known for milk
suitable for cheese
production origin
England soole known for heat tolerance
and disease
resistance origin pack Pakistan SL
India normande known for high protein to
Fat ratio ideal for chees making origin
France montard known for high yield milk
with excellent cheese making
properties origin
France red Cindy known for heat
resistance and quality mil production
origin Pakistan
these breeds are celebrated globally for
their unique attributes making them
ideal for various farming environments
and
purposes subscribe share and like for
more informative
videos thanks for watching the video and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for more watching